نتابع بسماع الخطاب المرحله
المعقده والصعبه بالنسبه لبلدنا
هناك تغيرات جذريه تجري في العالم اجمع
واحداث تاريخيه تحدد مستقبل بلدنا وشعبنا
وفي كل واحد منا هناك مسؤوليه وعلى كل
واحد منا مسؤوليه كبيره
ومن اجل حمايه مواطنين في اراضينا تاريخيه
وحمايه امن بلدنا
والتخلص من التهديدات التي جاءت من
النازيون من النازيين الجدد في اوكرانيا
منذ عام 2014 تم اتخاذ في العام الماضي
قرار ببدء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه وخطوه
تلو الخطوه
ونعمل على حل المسائل التي تقف امامنا
ومنذ عام 2014
ويدافع عن حقه في العيش على هذه الارض
ارضه ويتحدث بلغته الام
واجه الحصار والقصف الدائم
والكراهيه التي تاتي من النظام في
اوكرانيا وكان قد انتظر ان روسيا ستاتي
لمساعده هذا الشعب
وانتم تعلمون تماما اننا قمنا بكل ما
بوسعنا كل ما بوسعنا لحل هذه المساله
بالاساليب السلميه
واجرينا المحادثات
للخروج من هذه الازمه الصعبه
وكان هناك عده سنرال
ووعود
ممثلي الغرب
وتاكيداتهم بان السلام سيعم في الدومباس
ثبت انها خداع وكانوا يماطلون في الوقت
ويغلقون اعينهم عن القتل السياسيين
حتى بالمؤمنين
وايضا دعم الارهابيين بالاعمال الارهابيه
في
سيره استفنت انطالي ولقد
تشكيلات نازيه وقدموا لهم الاسلحه واؤكد
ايضا انه قبل بدء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
بنقل الاسلحه الى النظام في اوكرانيا من
الدفاع الجوي وغيرها من الاسلحه الثقيله
ودعموا النظام حتى حاولوا ان يقدموا لهذا
النظام الاسلحه النوويه وتحدثت عن هذا
علنا
ولقد نشعروا قواعدهم بالقرب من حدودنا
والمختبرات البيولوجيه
والنرجسوا المسرح العسكري
حتى اوكرانيا لحرب كبرى واليوم يعترفون
بهذا
ويعترفون بهذا علنا ولا يخجلون وهم
يفتخرون
خداعهم
وبغدرهم وباستخدام
اساليب الدبلوماسيه فقط كمسرحيه
في فتره
الماضيه يجري نزيف الدم في الدومباس
وروسيا كانت صريحه بالبحث عن الحل السلمي
بينما هم كانوا يخدعوننا وهذا الاسلوب
للخداع كان قد استخدم في السابق وكانوا قد
استخدموا ازدواجيه المعايير ايضا حين
دمروا
ولكنهم لن يستطيعوا ان يغسلوا هذا العار
عنهم
والثقه ليست بالنسبه لهم شيئا
وهم كانوا دائما يعملون على اساليب
الهيمنه ويستخدمونك كل ما لديهم من
امكانيات
وحتى ينظرون بنفس الطريقه الى شعوبهم وهم
يخدعون حتى شعوبهم
في انهم يبحثون عن السلام
اتجاه
بينما كان الخداع في كل مكان
مصالحنا وانما عن موقفنا بانه في العالم
الحديث لا يجب ان يكون هناك فصل بين الدول
حضاريه كما يسمى ودول اخرى
ان تكون موجوده في كل مكان
ونحن منفتحون للح البناء مع الغرب وتحدثنا
عن هذا واكدنا ان اوروبا والعالم بحاجه
الى الامن غير المجزا بالنسبه لكل الدول
ودعونا شركائنا بان نناقش هذه الفكره معا
ولكن في الرد كان هناك رده فعل خادعه
وحتى انه كان هناك تصرفات محدده فلقد توسع
الناتو الى حدودنا واقترب من حدودنا
وحاولوا ان يختبئوا خلف هذا
ونشروا القواعد العسكريه ليس فقط بالقرب
من الحدود الروسيه واؤكد انه بالنسبه
للجميع معروف انه ليس في اي دوله مثل هذا
العدد للقواعد
العسكريه مثل ما هو موجود لدى الولايات
المتحده فهي مئات واكد انها مئات القواعد
يكفي فقط ان ننظر الى الخريطه
ما يثبت ذلك كيف خرجوا من الاتفاقيات
الاساسيه في مجال التسليح
فلقد خرجوا من جهه واحده
والنسف الاتفاقات التي يمكن ان تدعم
السلام في العالم لماذا قاموا بذلك لا
يقومون باي شيء عبثا وفي
21 ارسلنا الى الولايات المتحده والناتو
ضمانات
ووفقا لهذه المبادئ
ردوا علينا بالرفض
وحينها اتضح انهم لديهم خطط عدائيه
ولا يرغبون ببناء اي علاقات وهذا التهديد
كان قد نمى يوما بعد يوم ووصل
من عام 22 سيحضرون لعمليه عقبيه في
الدومباس واذكر ان النظام في كيف منذ عام
2014 وكان قد ارسل الطائرات والدبابات الى
الدمباس ونحن نتذكر تلك اللحظات واللقطات
حيث قصفوا
الضربات ليس فقط الى تلك المدينه والى مدن
اخرى وفي عام 2015 حاولوا ان يهجموا
مباشره على
وقاموا بالحصار والترهيب والتخريب
وكل هذا كان يخالف تماما ما تم الاتخاذ
عليه اتخاذه في قرار مجلس الامن
اتجاه الحل السلمي لهذه القضيه ومره اخرى
اوكي بانهم هم الذين شنوا هذه الحرب ونحن
استخدمنا القوه ونستخدمها لوقف هذه الحرب
[تصفيق]
من خطط للهجوم الجديد على الدمباس كان
يعرف ان هدفه التالي هو الضربه الى القرم
وهم يعرفون هذا تماما والان الافكار في
كييف تتحدث وبصراحه
عن هذا الموضوع وانتم تعرفون هذا
نحن ندافع عن حياه السكان وبيتهم
اما الغرب فلقد صرف اكثر من 150 مليار
دولار لدعم العسكري النظام في كيف
وبينما لدعم الدول الفقيره كانوا خصصوا في
عام 21 60 مليار دولار
الى الحرب تجهزوا 150 مليار دولار وانما
لل الفقيره 60 مليار
وحتى انهم
اين الحديث
دائم عن التخلص من الفقر والحمايه البيئه
الى اين ذهبت هذه الاحاديث
ولكن تيار الاموال الى الحرب مستمر
وفي المؤتمر الاخير في ميونخ كان هناك
اتهامات عديده ضد روسيا ويبدو
وكانهم قاموا بهذا فقط من اجل ان ينسوا
جميعا ما قام به الغرب في عقود الماضيه
هم الذين اطلقوا الجن من القرن القاروره
ووفقا لتقييمات الخبراء الامريكيين فان
نتائج الحروب لسنا نحن الذين ابتكرنا هذه
الارقام فان الامريكيين هم الذين يتحدثون
عنها نتيجه الحروب التي شنتها الولايات
المتحده في القرن 21 كانوا قد قضوا على
اكثر من 900 الف نسمه وكان هناك عدد كبير
من الملايين من اللاجئين بسبب هذه الحروب
والان يسعون لي محو هذا من ذاكره الشعوب
وكانه لم يحدث لكن هذا لن ينساه احد
ينسى الضحايا
ولا يقومونهم باحصاء هذه الضحايا لان كان
يهمهم الارقام الاموال والتريليونات من
الدولارات
على اساس الديمقراطيه
يعملون
على اهانه الشعوب
وقعدتها
بخلقه
الاعداء يحاولون ان يلهوا الناس عن
الفضائح الموجوده لديهم
نقوم واذكر انه في الثلاثينات من القرن
الماضي فان هذا فتح الباب للنازيين الى
المانيا وفي وقتنا الحاضر هذا ما قاموا به
في اوكرانيا بمعاهدات روسيا هذا المشروع
بالنسبه للناس الذين يعرفون التاريخ
ان هذه الحرب كانت بدات من القرن التاسع
عشر في بولندا وفي دول اخرى بهدف واحد وهو
اقتطاع هذه المساحات التاريخيه التي تسمى
اليوم اوكرانيا عن اراضينا عن بلدنا
لم يكن هناك اي شيء جديد كل شيء يتكرر
الغرب
يحاول ان ينفذ هذا المشروع اليوم ودعم
حينها في الانقلاب في عام 2014 هذا
الانقلاب الدموي ضد الدوله وضد الدستور
وكانه كان يجب ان يقوم بذلك
كان هناك الكراهيه ضد الروس والنازيه
المتطرفه
من المخجل
نقلوا هذه الاسماء
لهذه الكتيبه النازيه التي شاركت في قتل
الاسرى
وفيا وايطاليا
هناك
شهره للاوسمه التي يحملونها بالنسبه التي
كانت تستخدم في فتره
الحرب الالمانيه النازيه
لا يخفون
بانهم يرثون اولئك
الاناسه من النازيين في المانيا
وكانه لا احد يلاحظ هذا الامر
ولانهم ويؤسفني ان اقول ذلك انهم يبصقون
على من
يرغب
ان يصحح هذا الامر
ومحاربوا ضد دولتنا
واستخدموا كل الامكانيات واستخدموا
الارهاب والنزيون ضدنا
حتى الشياطين لكي ينفذوا ايراداتهم لكي
اسلحه ضد روسيا وهذا المشروع ضد روسيا
لعدم الاستقرار بالقرب من حدودنا وفي
اكلاتينات من القرن الماضي
والان نفس الشيء وهو هدفه تحويل العداء
باتجاه الشرق
واشعال حرب في اوروبا بايدي غريبه والتخلص
من منافسهم
للنظام في اوكرانيا
ولاصحابه
وملاكه الذين احتلوا هذا البلد ولعقود
كانوا قد دمروا
الصناعه في اوكرانيا والثروات الباطنيه
فيها سرقوها
وقد انهار الوضع ووصل الى مستوى
كبير من الانهيار
ويستخدمون الناس كادوات للعمليات العسكريه
وفي الختام حولوهم الى مواد الاستهلاك من
المؤسف وهذا الامر واقعي
وان نمو الضحايا وعدد الضحايا كل هذه
المسؤوليه تقع على الدول الغربيه
والشعب الاوكراني بالنسبه لهم غريب
النظام الحالي لا يخدم المصالح الوطنيه
وانما مصالح الدول الثالثه الغرب يستخدم
اوكرانيا كواجهه لمواجهه روسيا وميدان
لمواجهه روسيا والغرب يحاول ان يكسر
العمليات العسكريه بضخ الاسلحه ونحن نعرف
هذا الامر ولكن الامر الاساسي يجب ان
يعرفه الجميع انه كلما زاد مدى الاسلحه
التي ستصل الى اوكرانيا كلما
كنا مضطرون ان نبعد هذا التهديد عن حدودنا
وهذا امر طبيعي
رغبتها كما يقولون مباشره
الهزيمه الاستراتيجي بنسبه شهاده ماذا
يعني بنسبه
تدمير روسيا فهم يريدون تحويل هذا الصراع
الى حاله الى حاله حرب عالميه او مواجهه
عالميه
فنحن ندرك كل هذا بهذا الطريق وبهذه
الطريق سوف نرد على كل هذا في هذا الظرفيه
يضر الحديث عن وجود دولتنا
فهوم
يعتبرون ان ان هزيمه روسيا على حلبه
السراء من المستحيل فتابعا تدور حمله
اعلاميه عدوانيه عبر الشباب مثلا عبر
الاجيال الجديده فهو يكذبون دائما ويقوم
بتحريف الحقائق التاريخيه
ويهجمون على الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الروسيه
وغيرها من
مؤسسات دوله روسيه
انظروا الى تصرفاتهم في دورهم اذا ما
تحدثنا عن القيم العائليه والشباب
والاطفال وحتى البداخليه كل هذه
الاخلاقيات التبعيه بنسبه لهم في حياتهم
اما فيما يتعلق بمتدينين فهم يتعرضون الى
التنكير الى التنكيل والمعاقبات
وطبعا هوم
يريدون الحياه بهذه الطريقه
هو لا احد يتدخل في الحياه الشخصيه
ولكن
بوجه ان اقول لهم طبعا هناك
المخططات الدينيه المهمه وهي تشمل الحقائق
لان العائله هي
الاتحاد ما بين المراه
بين السيد والسيده
فكل هذه المخططات تتعرض الى النفاق
الكنيسه
الانجليزيه البريطانيه تريد تحريف مختلفه
المقررات الدينيه
المتعلقه بربنا
مليون ملايين الناس في الغرب يفهمون كل
هذا انه في طريقي الكارثه والهاويه النخب
يتعرضون الى الجنون وهذا الجنون مستعصي
الشفاء فتابعا هذه هي مشاكلهم يجب علينا
الدفاع عن اطفالنا في كل هذه الظرفيه من
التقهقر في الثقافه والحضاره وحط في الدين
من الجلي جدا ان الغرب سوف يحاول زعزعه
مجتمعنا وتفتيت مجتمعنا عن طريق محاولات
مختلفه
في الاستفاده من هذه المواد السامه لاولئك
الذين يريدون دفع
عليها اولئك الذين يقومون باعمال ارهابيه
ضد مجتمعنا ووحده
واراضينا سوف يتحملون المسؤوليه
ولن نحظى حضره نظام كيف وليك الذين
يقومون باصطياد
الاشباح طبعا نحن
فلنترك ذلك في ضميرهم فليعيشوا مع ذلك
المهم بالنسبه لنا ان الناس والمواطنين في
روسيا
يفهمون كل ذلك ويقيمون ذلك ونحن نفتخر
جميعا بان شعبنا متعدد القوميات
[تصفيق]
الاغلبيه الساحقه تتخذ موقفا مبدئيا من
حيث العمليه العسكريه الخاصه وفهموا هذه
الاغراض والاهداف الخاصه بحمايه
في المقام الاول
الوطنيه
والاحساس الذي يعود الى شعبنا تاريخيا
وحضاريا ونحن نفتخر بكل هذا وكل واحد منا
يفهم ذلك
كانه جزء لا يتجزء منا الوطنيه من دولهنا
ومن وطننا
[تصفيق]
شكرا للجميع وللشعب روسيا عالم البساله
ولابطالنا وجنودنا
وبحارتنا
وموظفين في المخابرات واجهزه الامنيه في
المتطوعين والوطنيين الذين يحاربون في
صفوف مجموعه برص
وطبعا بودزي ان
يؤسفني للاسف الشديد ان اسمي جميع جميع
اولئك الذين يشاركون عند التحضير من هذه
الرساله رساله طبعا عدد كبير من كل هذه
المجموعات المشاركه
وللاسف الشديد لا يمكن التسميه جميع
المجموعات بسبب ضيق الوقت
وانحانيا امامكم وانحاني امام كل اسره
[تصفيق]
اسره لاولئك الذين يشاركون في هذه العمليه
وممرضات واطباء
وموظفين في سكك الحديد واولئك الذين
يعملون في المصانع والمعامل وفي ورش
الاصلاح
وغيرهم
الذين يعملون على مدار الساعه
الشكر لكم جميعا
[تصفيق]
والمعلمين والمعلمات الذين يعتنون
بشبابنا واولئك الذين يعملون في ظروف
عصيبه قربا جبهات القتال وشخصيات فنيه
تزور المشافي والمستشفيات لدعم الضحايا
والمتطورين الذين يعملون من اجل دولهنا
والصحفيين في المقام الاول الحربيين الذين
يخاطرون بحياتهم فهم يبثون الحقيقه والصدق
وشخصيات الدين
واولئك الذين
يعملون لكل هذه الاغراض الخاصه والمانوطه
بدعم
كريسنا الخاصه واولئك الذين يعملون
ويقومون بواجهه بوجه
بواجبهم
المدني وحتى العسكري وطبعا كلمات خاصه
لمواطنين انتم
بتقرير مصيركم اثناء الاستفتاء واتخذوا
قرارا
اثناء هذه الاوقات الصعبه اذن مشاهدينا
استمعنا ولا نزال للخطاب السنوي للرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين الذي شدد فيه على عده نقاط
بوتين تحدث بانهم سيقررون مهام العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا خطوه بخطوه
بان الغرب ايضا يسعى لتحويل صراع محلي الى
نزاع عالمي بوتين ايضا جدد التفكير
بمخاوفه التي دفعته لاطلاق هذه العمليه
العسكريه ضد اوكرانيا منها التوسع الناتو
على حدوده ونشر قواعد عسكريه بالقرب من
روسيا وايضا اعتبر بانه بلده تواجه خطرا
وجوديا من المستحيل هزمتها في ارض المعركه